[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
the war crime prosecutor
following the money
I mean if you think about it you're like
why why in the hell does Jack Smith
need
need records about foreign payments that
Donald Trump may have been paid when it
comes to documents hmm that seems odd
right I mean what the hell does that
have to do with documents unless
unless maybe just maybe
I'm just saying here
maybe someone received a payment for a
certain type of document I don't I don't
know I don't know I guess we'll find out
when Donald Trump is indicted because he
is going to be in debt folks if if you I
I don't know do you remember I don't
know
a couple months ago we found out before
the Durham report dropped we found out
that bill Barr
and John Durham went overseas to look
into
foreign transactions made by Hillary
Clinton
and what they found was people were
digging up like well not Hillary Clinton
but Trump here you go here's some
[__] crimes and they're like whoa
whoa here are no evil see no evil speak
no evil you don't want to see that
maybe that's what it is I you know it
could be an array of things really
but if you're standing around still
wondering if Donald Trump is receiving
[__] corrupt money from foreign
governments you are a dumb son of a
[__] like you just don't get how this
is working and how he's appeared to be
rich since the early 90s you know that
right like you think he's some kind of
successful business person because you
watched a fake ass reality show in a
fake board room where he was fake firing
people literally you think that's his
Pinnacle of success where he was paid
several million dollars to pretend to be
a really successful business person he's
a really good money launderer and rushed
the Russian since the early 90s have
made sure of that you stupid [__]
you again
if you can't if you can't figure out
this [__]
then you're you're either one in the
cult or two just too dumb to I don't
know read [__]
it's not complicated to understand that
Trump has been receiving corrupt foreign
money Jesus Christ that's what he was
using the hotel in Washington for
come on
we all know this it's right out there in
the open Trump never never hides the
quiet party it says the quiet part out
loud hell this morning this morning he
was he was posting about e Gene Carol
I'm like what the [__] happened
something had to happen something
happened that [__] pissed Trump off
and he's and he's telling on himself
again and it's and it's here's another
Trump news e Gene Carroll goes to the
judge in his defamation suit and says
hey [__] this guy's still
defaming me you gotta get until he stops
defaming you have to keep awarding me
money
he's doing the same defamation that you
just awarded me money for
I want you to amend it and she's
probably gonna get it
because he won't shut his [__] mouth
which he has the right to remain silent
he just does not have the [__]
capability
and honestly
having said that that's what is really
going to save us from this [__]
nincompoop ever having the Reigns of
power ever again because he just can't
[__] shut the [__] up he can't he
won't
his best bet his best bet in 2020
was to admit he lost concede and slink
away to Mar-A-Lago he would have lived
his life
high on the Russian money laundering hog
high high on the foreign payments hog
nope couldn't do that couldn't admit it
had to try to commit a coup when he
couldn't commit the coup he went down to
Mar-A-Lago and stole out documents to
sell them that's what the [__] he did to
cover up January 6 and sell him what do
you think the [__] the Saudi the
Saudi golf tournament is
you think they just love Trump
huh
and only Trump Golf properties that's
what you think
come on
he he [__] paid him in classified
documents I think that's what we're
gonna find out I think that's what we're
gonna find out I think that's why Jack
Smith was able to subpoena these records
and they allowed him to do it because
Trump tried to stop it folks
he's in big [__] trouble but the
crazy part is
the crazy part is
because of the cult
he is still in the running for the
nomination that's the only reason
and Ron DeSantis
Rhonda scientists can't figure out why
the Florida Republicans
won't allow him to be governor and run
for president he's like why won't you
just pass this law because they were
they were expected to pass this quickly
nope still hanging on to it the Florida
Republicans won't move
by June 1st
he's I mean a tiny D is dying to get in
this race
so his little D cult
which
it's few and far between we showed the
video yesterday of him in a diner
this [__] this [__] fascist
Android in a skin suit
good Lord
dude Governor weirdo man listen choose
Ron choose and you're gonna I've been
telling you for [__] weeks man get in
the race dude you are not gonna be able
to do this if you don't get in now
you're you're a joke Ron you're a
[__] joke you're destroying your
state
which I understand what you're trying to
do right what you're trying to do is
remain Governor so that you can show how
fascist you want the United States to be
how do you want to how you want to
Florida the United States
well people aren't popular it's not a
popular opinion you're you're [__]
fascism that you have in Florida
it's not a thing that the rest of the
country wants it's it's just not
place the hell hole at this point you
can't even get people to show up on a
construction site to build houses
anymore
so Ron my advice is just get in man
resign as Governor because really that's
your best chance anyways is to resign as
Governor you you know that if you remain
governor and try to run that Trump is
going to knock you every single day
every [__] day every day that you're
running for president not being Governor
he's gonna [__] nail you on it man
and it's it's gonna stick It's Gonna
Keep sticking
because he's got a cult and the cult's
gonna vote in the primary you're not
running a general election run you dumb
[__]
how I I can't even I can't even [__]
I can't stand it anymore honestly this
is pissing me off and and it's and it's
it's political analyst that analyzed
these [__] Races they don't know what
the [__] they're talking about anymore
they just don't
for years they were half-handed and for
years they were half right half wrong
but if you don't see if you don't see
what's gonna happen this race like
yesterday Tim Scott announced get the
[__] out of here that guy's gonna spend
20 million dollars to make sure Ronda
santis can't go anywhere in the race
that's what Tim Scott's in this for you
think Tim Scott is in this race to
[__] win get the [__] out of here if
you watch that announcement yesterday
there is no chance in [__] hell not
not a goddamn chance in hell that Tim
Scott will ever ever win a primary race
or a delegate
because it feels like to me that there's
going to be information come out about
Tim Scott
Republicans are already like yeah um
[Music]
South Carolina likes to elect
Senators that you know
had the closet door closed is what some
would say
they were alluding to it on on morning
jail the other day Jewish Scarborough
was like yeah the senators from South
Carolina really
really you're on the anti-gay agenda
um come on now
Ted Cruz did an interview and Ted Cruz
is like look ah I don't know I don't
know uh what do you see it's gonna get
vicious
yeah but Tim Scott has a war chest of 20
million dollars
and he's going to use that 20 million
dollars to make sure Trump becomes the
nominee
why do you why do you think these people
are getting in the race
they're not going to compete for number
one okay in this primary they have to
compete for number two
they can't compete for number one that's
not how it [__] works
you have to you have to you have to make
the primary voters believe that there's
a head-to-head match
and if you're number three four five
really and and the realistic realm of
polls are pulling our opinion you're
gonna try to get to number two
[__] being number one
[__] being number one you just want a
head-to-head match
and that way you can try to win in that
space
because it doesn't matter how if you win
every single primary
you just have to win enough delegates
and let me tell you something folks if
if you don't if you're not aware of this
Trump is Gonna Get Enough delegates to
win on the first ballot that's what's
gonna happen
I don't give a [__] how many indictments
he has what the indictments are for I
don't even give a [__] if they if they
put an ankle bracelet on him and make
him stay at Mar-A-Lago he's gonna have
enough delegates
when you when you when you pair the cult
the manga cult with affiliation voting
the rest of these candidates don't have
a chance in hell and then and then you
put together with when you pair with the
the affiliation
and the cult you pair his incumbency
folks there is a lot of people out there
it's not a big percentage but there's a
lot of people out there that still think
he's the [__] president
it's a [__] line it's delusional it's
crazy ass [__] yeah it sounds like a
[__] movie
but these people are living in the Q
Anon world
and I'm telling you they still think
he's the [__] president
and if you don't think that amounts to
some kind of incumbency you are [__]
brain dead
I've been telling you since the end of
December Trump will be the nominee no
matter what I mean barring some sort of
accident where a big Max gets lodged or
something that's it
that's it he's gonna be the [__]
nominee
but our job our job as as the
pro-democracy coalition
is the number one not lose sight of that
race
because I'm very confident in that race
very confident at this point
you think rock you think Ron DeSantis is
going to win the nomination [__] out of
here that [__] weirdo why are you
kidding me I can't even I can't even
believe that some [__] is a governor of
a state at this point I'm like what the
[__] how the [__] did that happen
but he does he does not have what it
takes on a national stage he just
doesn't
he doesn't he's too [__] weird he's
too awkward
now
if you consider
what is the most important thing
about 2024
it is the house the Senate and the state
races folks and we have to find
Democrats who are win run and win in
these State races we have to we have to
make inroads on taking away the super
majority of Republicans
it is crucial to our long-term strategy
to to propel democracy
they're trying to smash it up
now they the Republicans did a really
good job
of absolutely killing
liberals
in these state governments
and making sure to box them out
but in the last two years
when they saw that the cult would buy
the big lie that Trump [__] won they
were like well we can sell them anything
we say these people will believe they're
like trans people just existed they are
they just the Liberals just came up with
transgender people
because they're gonna take over the
world or some weird ass [__]
gays they're everywhere and they're
trying to make your children gay which
is not the truth
it's weird [__]
passing walls about bathrooms that do
the opposite of what they say they want
yelling and screaming about Bud Light
and Target and M MS
they've lost the plot line folks
they've lost their grip on their
long-term strategy
Republicans in this country had a really
good long-term strategy for a long time
and it was bottom up
in government
City councils School boards
state governments executive branches and
state governments
into the house into the United States
Senate
that's how they got their minority
ideology to control large sloths of our
country
and to push their fascism
but they got greedy because they're
[__] Republicans
and they've shown their cards
and if we don't use it if we don't use
this to politicize this and make 2024
more about just the top of the ticket
because we can't take our eyes off that
ball oh [__] we cannot take our eyes off
that ball
but we must we must push and engage our
democracy all the way down the ballot
the entire way down
and the only way to do that is to find
people who will run as a Democrat folks
I'm telling you in some of these states
these people who have voted Republican
for their entire [__] life are only
voting for Republicans their entire life
because it's the only [__] on
the ballot
they would put their check next to a d
if they had the option
thank you
they would vote for a Democrat if they
had the option especially now especially
with these crazy [__] are doing
to their states
we can [__] win in places like Ohio
we can win in places like Georgia and we
don't need a Stacey Abrams I keep
hearing that [__] I keep hearing
that [__] Stacey Abrams is a [__]
Warrior Stacy Abrams is is one of the
main reasons why Georgia is turning blue
and it's not turning blue it was blue
she just gave it proof
we can do the same thing as a National
Coalition everywhere
we don't need a Stacey Abrams in every
state when you say that that
self-defeedism
that you need someone anyone to give you
the hope to go out and engage just
engage just do it
it really is not that hard
and it's a long road
and listen I understand that it is tough
because
liberal democracy is way tougher than
authoritarianism folks way tougher
we have we have to all get in a room
where we disagree but we have to agree
on a few things to make sure that we
that we perpetuate Propel our government
Propel our Republic towards equality and
Equity give ourselves the freedom and
the rights to deliver us Liberty
and it's difficult we don't all agree
and that the reason why is because we're
a big Coalition a huge Coalition of
pro-democracy mindset
and it becomes an issue when you have to
agree with each other but there's one
thing we can agree on
one thing we can agree on
is that fascism is not the way to
democracy
and because Republicans have deluded
their entire [__] base and they know
they can sell anything they want to to
them they can grift any stupid [__]
idea Jesus Christ yesterday that this is
going around right now
and we're going to talk about this a bit
today with Texas Paul I'm sure because
today's Tuesday
so it's got Texas Pawn here but here's
the thing
there was a 19 year old
from Missouri
he rent a U-Haul truck he's going to
crash into the White House
he hit a Ballard our big post that is
designed to stop vehicles
and it stopped this U-Haul truck
they apprehended this this 19 year old
man from Manchester which is up by St
Louis Missouri
and in the truck in the rental truck he
had a backpack full of [__] one of the
things in the truck was a Nazi flag now
people are confused I guess he's of
Indian descent
so they're confused about this again
this is the same kind of [__] that we
had at the Allen Texas shooting
well how can he be a white supremacist
look do we have to keep telling you that
you don't have to be white to be a white
supremacist and buy into the ideas of
white supremacy you dumb [__]
how many times do we have to say this
how many times do we have to tell you
that ideology doesn't necessarily have
to match your skin color okay
or your background for that matter the
internet's a [__]
and it can brainwash and delude people
into all kinds of crazy [__] that
doesn't make sense on its face
but here's the thing
the authorities apprehend this person
they pull the evidence out of the truck
now if you've ever rented a U-Haul you
know that the U-Haul is completely
[__] empty when you're in it
completely [__] empty nothing in it
the only thing that goes in the U-Haul
is anything you put in the U-Haul okay
got it are you are you clear on how
rental trucks work
so this guy had a backpack full of [__]
when you ran the truck you put it in the
truck they pulled it out of the truck
they pulled the [__] out of his backpack
they laid it on the ground to take
pictures of the [__] that was in his
backpack and the one reason why is
because they were searching the [__]
truck for explosives and bombs you dumb
sons of [__]
and they took a picture of it and it was
laying out on the ground so they're like
oh look it's a false flag it's a false
flag
look when you're defending Nazis I don't
care what their name is what their
background is what their skin if you're
defending Nazis and you're defending the
ideology of Nazis by saying it's the
feds it's a false flag your Nazi
sympathizer which makes you a [__]
Nazi
Nazi sympathizers aren't just
sympathizers they're Nazis too
okay got it are you are you clear on
that
are you okay now you [__] weirdos who
are who are completely triggered by the
fact that some domestic terrorist who's
got a [__] truck who's trying to
Ramen into the White House
has got a Nazi flag you get [__]
triggered that's weird [__] man that's
weird stuff it says way more about you
than it even says about the Nazi
domestic terrorist to be quite honest
it says way more about you way more and
the fact and the fact that you think
that the feds planted the Nazi flag come
on man I mean I'm I'm not saying that
the FBI
is the dumbest law enforcement agency
but to think that all law enforcement
agents have the foresight to carry
around the Nazi flag to plan it in the
U-Haul truck
[__] out of here with this [__] man
and frankly law enforcement's on your
guys's side we watched that this week
when the D.C police officer was indicted
for [__] tipping off Enrique tarrio
you you know you know that the you know
that Trump loved police remember
remember blue lives matter you remember
that [__] you remember the Blue Line the
American flags with the blue line in
them you remember that [__] oh man they
love that [__] the right wing oh man
they [__] love you cow you are you're
against police you want to defund police
hmm seems kind of weird
and you change your mind
but here's a long and the short of it
speaking of law enforcement
here's a long and short of it Donald
Trump will be indicted by Jack Smith my
guess is sometime this fall my guess is
Jack Smith is still turning over rocks
wherever they may lead he's turning
these rocks over and finding these
[__] frauds these Crooks these
criminals that are tied to Trump and
he's finding his Crooks his crimes
underneath these rocks and he's gonna
follow this wherever the [__] it goes
and to think to think that the documents
case in January 6 led to Jack Smith
uncovering foreign transactions and
foreign payments
between Trump and foreign governments
like Saudi Arabia and turkey hmm just
seems kind of convenient I don't know
maybe it's just me maybe I'm the
conspiracy theorist I guess we'll find
out when Jack Smith indicts him and
other Trump news Jesus Christ just
doesn't I I got a few minutes before the
bottom of the hour here in other Trump
news he's apparently going to appear on
a zoom meeting today
for his gag order I don't know if it's
an official gag order out of the
Manhattan D.A are the Manhattan uh
Courthouse but apparently the judge is
going to tell him what he can and cannot
say
can't be saying this [__] and you
noticed you noticed that uh Donald Trump
has not been attacking the Manhattan D.A
like he was now right right until his
indictment
um
I hope he doesn't shut up I I hope I
wish he would do a rally every [__]
day at Mar-A-Lago I wish he would get
out in front of a microphone and record
himself talking over and over and over
again
if you don't see that he is digging his
own [__] political and criminal grave
and you're dumb and you should not want
to take the shovel out of his hand let
him self-destruct
so there's three big pieces of news in
Trump criminal matters and Trump legal
matters
Eugene Carroll's asking for more money
because he can't stop defaming her and
the crazy part is is like she goes and
asks the judge she's like hey give me
more money because the [__]
keeps doing the same defamation he was
just accused of and and convicted of
and he gets on true social
and he defames her even more
only only making sure that the judge is
probably gonna rule an aging Carol's
favor for more money what a dumb
[__] hey keep going Grandpa keep
going man keep talking great story keep
going my friend everybody it's Tuesday
it's Taco Tuesday but it's Texas fall
Tuesday I'm super excited to have Texas
ball today I can't wait to see what he
has for us on some of these uh these
stories Trump stories but also
what he's found out maybe about the this
uh DC trucker Nazi terrorist it's kind
of weird kind of a weird story we're
gonna find out uh more about it
um and I think he's got a story he wants
to talk about here he's messaging me
something
but we'll we'll get into it we're gonna
get to it don't forget don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
here on YouTube you're not going to want
to miss a single episode every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch speaking and Twitter
follow us at Tony Michaels pod download
every single episode if you want to
listen to the audio version I'll tell
you that's a huge favor that you could
do that's free too just go download
every single episode it gives us more in
the algorithms if you download it
on your favorite favorite directory give
us a great review while you're there if
you want to watch it on Facebook you can
watch us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels you can watch live or re-watch
on our Facebook page you can also find
us on Twitch
kind of cool
I I got I gotta say you guys are [__]
awesome the greatest audience in the
world did you know it's free to follow
us on Twitch and a lot of people were
saying they didn't know how to set up a
Twitch account
so I think what I'll do
um is I will find a video on YouTube
that shows you how to set up a Twitch
account
um and really honestly you can just go
to YouTube and just type in how to set
up a Twitch account and I'm sure there's
going to be a video there that will
easily explain it and you can either
download the app or you can go to
twitch.tv twitch.tv that's the that's
the uh the URL and you can go set up a
Twitch account now
we've got 192 subscribers with Amazon
Prime on our Twitch account which is
[__] amazing we're so close to the
200 of our goal our first goal of 200
subscribers we're only eight away so if
you have an Amazon Prime account listen
up if you have an Amazon Prime account
you can link it to a Twitch account
and with that Twitch account you can
give us one free subscription that you
get with your Amazon Prime account when
you link them
so you give us that one free
subscription through Amazon gaming which
is part of your Amazon Prime account
and that gives us that free subscription
and you have to redo it every single
month I know free money isn't
easy but it's easy to re-subscribe it's
easy to subscribe with Prime
and then you resubscribe every month we
just got 193 so thank you uh Paula Amel
I think it's what the uh
the person's name is there and dark sire
just to subscribe for three months thank
you very much thank you thank you thank
you so
if you guys want to give us monetary
support and it not cost you a single
extra nickel
the best way to do it is with your
Amazon Prime account and your Twitch
account you link the two you give us
that one free subscription and we get a
couple bucks each month and we
appreciate all the support that you give
us rather you go to our patreon and give
us money rather you go to the tip jar at
the Tony michaels.com that's
d20michaels.com you can find the tip jar
there thank you for everyone in the last
few weeks that has been giving us tips
there I I know we can't do Super Chat on
YouTube because they won't monetize me
because of my [__] mouth
um
you just don't I don't like the [__] I
say I guess they don't want to monetize
me and I know a lot of people like the
super chats so you get credit in the
chat
um but honestly
if you want to do it that way you can go
to the Tony michaels.com you can throw
whatever you were going to throw in the
Super Chat in the tip jar and we
appreciate all that support here at the
show it keeps us going every single
weekday but more than anything the thing
that means the most to me is everyone
coming here every single weekday
watching from the very beginning of the
show to the very end you're the best
audience you guys engage not just on
YouTube but on Facebook and on Twitch
it's incredible you guys are incredible
you're the best audience in the world
and I hope you share this link I hope
you share this show with your friends
your family and your fellow thinkers
even if some of your friends and family
are Maga share it with them too I love
when people love me but I love when
people love to hate me oh my God don't
go anywhere we're gonna be right back
with Texas Paul right after this break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
holy moly
195.
we're at 192 just a few moments ago
for Prime
subscribers on Twitch
[Music]
everyone gave out a
Community sub gift I wish I could bring
these up I gotta figure out a tool where
I can bring these up from twitch I know
that's kind of like a thing on Twitch
um to bring stuff up and I know we need
to get the emotes and stuff I'm trying
to figure out how twitch works because
it's a little different than YouTube
because it's like a it's like a real
streaming
um platform right it's not like YouTube
where you just post videos and those
videos live there forever we stream a
show to Twitch if you guys don't know
you just stream the show to Twitch uh
live and it'll live there for I don't
know it's like three or four days I
haven't figured that out either and you
guys can go make Clips over there
like if you have a favorite part of the
show you can actually you can make a
clip of the show and and it'll be on the
channel the twitch Channel
um and I I can make a clip of the show
and I think it stays on there for a
really long time like a year or
something
so
um
[Laughter]
um but we're up to 195 now you guys are
the greatest in the world you really are
I I'll tell you the reason why I decided
to do this full time and to not not not
give this up and and to try to maybe
undo some of my other
um commitments that I had and I've taken
a pay cut for this to be quite honest to
come here and do this because I know in
the long run
my audience you guys are the best in the
world you're United you guys love each
other uh and and ultimately I will
succeed
I will succeed at this and the reason
why is because of you
because you come here every single day
and you listen and you go out and you
message and you talk about your
democracy you engage in your democracy
and it's not because of me maybe there's
a cathartic release here it gives you
that that motivation
and maybe I give you a certain
perspective on issues certain commentary
and I appreciate that you guys come here
every single day because I could not do
this without you I mean I could but it
wouldn't last very [__] long so you
guys mean the world to me even you
[__] out there that love to
come in and Troll and hate on me you
mean the world to me too you guys you
you're pumping my algorithm you guys
really I had a video on Instagram that I
did about Trump I don't know it's like
[__] four weeks ago five weeks ago
and the trolls got all of it and they
were like ah you're a dumb son of a
[__] and it like doubled in the views
like just like in three days I was like
thank you so much thank you so much for
coming in and give me the hate because
now you're making sure that my message
gets out to more people thank you it
really helps it really does
but more than anything the audience
means the world to me and the reason why
is because again I would not be able to
do this and I would not have the
prospect of doing this for the next
however long it takes I don't care if it
takes a decade two decades three decades
I mean I'm not I'm not extremely young a
lot of people think I'm younger than I
am
I'm almost 40. I'm getting there but
I've got I've got many years to go and I
can yell and scream into this microphone
for decades
and it's because of you and it's because
of how we're going to grow it's because
of the Coalition that we're going to
build the [__] fam is strong and
really honestly there's a bunch of
people and someone said the other day
something about curse words and not
having curse words or swear words I'm
like get the [__] out of here you don't
let the door hit you where the good Lord
splits you okay I'm not gonna stop
cussing people I've had people call me
you know who they were if I send them
out loud I'm just not gonna add them
here on the air called me and told me
Tony if you just stay off that f word
you just calm that f word down you can
be on ass XM you'd be syndicated
and said well [__] what what the [__]
good would that do can you imagine can
you imagine the Tony Michaels podcast
without the [__] f word are you
kidding me
can you imagine my commentary without
you know being peppered with swear words
give me a break
that's what the audience comes here for
is my my profanity poetry hello
that's what they come here for
for that cathartic release someone said
on the uh patreon uh Sunday wrenth year
they got goddamn because uh on Sundays
um we do a patreon rant it's it's only
open to patreon but last week I opened
it up to the public and someone said
damn Tony's red
in the face yeah I [__] get pissed
off
I get pissed off it I know this is your
cathartic release I know what I'm saying
is what you're thinking and sometimes
isn't what you can say out loud
and I know I am a certain way of putting
together curse words I understand it
again it's it's profanity poetry
that's the way I see it I think my
record on a 60 60 second clip
I think my record was 21 [__]
in 60 seconds in the 60 second clip and
I made a good point it wasn't just the
[__] like it wasn't just the word [__]
I just said it 21 times and it made a
damn good point damn good impact but
that's profanity poetry okay and I'm not
gonna give that up I think the audience
likes that about me I think the audience
respects that about me because that's
the authentic me
I curse a lot I don't have to curse
I prefer to
I prefer to a lot of people prefer to
curse I mean you can hold back your your
cursing right you don't have to curse
but why wouldn't you why wouldn't you oh
my gosh look oh my gosh thank you so
much we just had another another sub
with Prime and we had time Time Bandit
Jared give out five Community Subs as
gifts we're at 201
holy [__] [__]
see what I mean see what I mean
about being the best audience in the
entire [__] world I really truly mean
it and guys I want you to understand
something even if you're out there and
you can't afford to give the show any
money it's okay I want you here too I
want you here too I want you to come and
engage in the chats whether it's on
Twitch whether it's on Facebook whether
it's on on Twitter on my Twitter page or
Instagram
Facebook YouTube come and engage this
audience not only not only is this
audience
welcoming and we have the best
moderators in the world to help welcome
you to the [__] fam
but we give support here in these chats
and I see it every day I read a lot of
your guys messages a lot of the message
and engagement isn't even with me in the
show
you guys are talking to each other
and that's my goal my goal is to get you
to engage in your democracy
and it's not just coming here and and
and getting clout in the chat
it's about engaging talking to each
other knowing each other knowing that
you have allies out there knowing that
the [__] that they're trying to sell
you in the media that oh my God half the
country's Maga is [__] it's absolute
[__] it's not real
the idea that we're split 50 50 is
[__] dumb
and you guys are a prime example of that
and I'm telling you as we get more
haters are are people who love to hate
me in the chat I know you guys are gonna
welcome them love them even though they
hate you
and give them love enough and maybe
maybe just maybe they listen long enough
maybe just maybe
they'll start to come around to the idea
that democracy is good for everyone
and it lifts all boats
so let's get to the Tuesday I'm sorry I
went on kind of a tangent there Texas
ball is waiting I know he doesn't mind
though when I'm talking about the
audience and the um
and now they can go Texas Paul my friend
how are you today
well you gotta unmute and that would
help I know you're probably waiting
that's why you had it on mute yeah I
don't like to make noise in the
background while you're talking I
apologize for that I am glad to be I'm
really super excited to be here actually
I'm I'm pumped up about today yeah is
there a specific story that you're
pumped up about or is there you just I
know you like being on the show I know
this is like because this is my happy
place Texas ball every single day enjoy
it and I I know you love coming here
every Tuesday
um I wish we could get you on the show
more than just Tuesday yeah you're not
you're not gonna go with the hat today
look at that look I gotta run this game
I'm telling you I got some hair man you
got some hair you got some hair I'm not
like one of them old white supremacists
white dudes wear a cowboy hat because
he's got a big ass bald spot there I
wear it because I like it yeah I mean
well you're from Texas right I should
give me a goddamn uh a cowboy hat or
Sombrero right is that well tell us tell
the audience the difference because
there is a is there a difference in in
uh cowboy hat and a in a sombrero yeah
yeah and a lot of people don't know that
everything that is Cowboy came from came
from Mexico no it all did hey easy
easy on that Texas easy on the history
and easy on the truth my friend
you're gonna piss the righties off if
you're not careful
the Mexicans were smarter about it they
had hats with bigger brims because they
live down in the Mexican Badlands the
Sonoran Desert all that so they needed
something to keep the sun off so they
had hats with a big ass brims on them
and that's where we get the sombreros
from uh you know Whitey tighties like me
we went with a little smaller brim
because it's easier to get through your
Walmart you know right uh does the same
thing keeps the Sun out of your eyes you
know but but it's not nearly as big
that's the only difference really
between the Cowboy and the sombrero is
the size of the brand just the size of
the brim so where where does it where
does the the cowboy hat stop and the
sombrero begin then
it depends on the size of your penis
Tony oh okay I get it
oh man there's a whole formula right
there there's a hole for me okay I got
you I got you I got you so you're saying
Republicans have to have a really big
[__] brim for it to be a sombrero is
what you're saying because oh no it's
just the opposite okay most Republicans
put on one of those little monkey hats
you know what I mean with the they're
that big and that would be a sombrero I
see I see so it's just the ratio of the
the little dick energy you know yeah uh
yesterday I think it was we actually um
stop talking about dicks God damn it
um so
oh you know you love to come on the show
but sometimes I don't think she likes
when you come on the show and to be
going on and she's like no she loves
your show man she really likes no she's
here everyday I think she watches it
almost every day she's here yeah yeah
she got mad at me because you know I
like the [__] hats yourself I really
do I keep one right here I do I keep it
right here on my desk I sit here when
I'm working this at another but she's
sitting there brainstorming trying to
come up with a new hat for you because
she's like has barred me from where I
put one on the other day we were going
down to Sam's and she's like get it off
take it off you're not walking through
yeah you're not walking through the city
you're gonna get us kicked out of Santa
but she is literally trying to
brainstorm you a new hat right now yeah
well you know
um we we've considered a lot of things
I've considered because I have I
actually have a uh a censored [__]
logo
um and I I don't I don't want to tell
the story of why it is but but I do have
a censored version I haven't used it in
a long time because I [__] hate it I
[__] hate the censored version and
really honestly I it makes me proud it
makes me proud that that you may get
kicked out of sans by wearing my hat
that actually makes me that makes me
really excited if people are getting
kicked out of grocery stores and stuff
because they got my hat on that that
pleases me more than you'll ever [__]
know to be going on this so so um um I I
I love Miss Texas fault Mrs Texas Ball
but
let him wear the Hat and Sam see what
happens I'm just saying I'm just saying
I'm just saying let him wear the hat and
see me on the news fighting 20 hillbilly
boys
oh [__] well no I was really excited to
come on today because of the news from
last night you know you I mean you we
got this dip [__] uh Sai varshath uh
condula I believe his name is you're
talking about one of your boys well in
Chesterfield he is from Manchester no is
he from Chesterfield Missouri is it
Chesterfield yes okay yeah excuse me I I
misspoke early when I said mentioned
Chesterfield well they got it wrong they
got it wrong when they first id'd him oh
really okay yeah he's from Chesterfield
so Chesterfield Missouri is um is that a
a higher end neighborhood up in the St
Louis area uh people don't know
um if you go to Chesterfield it's it's
just full of [__] big mcmansions and
and and shopping malls and restaurants
and and that's all you know it's a bunch
of [__] strip malls is what it is
with um you know pizza joints and taco
places and and and stores and all kinds
of [__]
um and it looks all brand new because it
is kind of brand new as far as St Louis
is concerned so Chesterfield is is kind
of a
um you would call it the ritzy area it's
not exactly the richest area in St Louis
but it is one of the more affluentant
areas in in St Louis Missouri I mean
that's my experience
um and and going up there and driving
through Chesterfield and eating at a few
restaurants there
um yeah it's just just west of St Louis
isn't it yeah well I mean it it's like
in The Burbs out to the West right but
people from Chesterfield say they live
in Chesterfield
um if you're from St Louis Chesterfield
is St Louis if that makes sense right uh
that makes perfect sense we got that
around here too right the people people
in in Chesterfield don't want to admit
that they live in Saint I live in
Chesterfield right because it's kind of
like a badge of honor type [__] but um
people in St Louis or the St Louis area
consider Chesterfield part of St Louis
metro I mean because it is part of St
Louis metro you can't tell where
Chesterfield stops and ends right I mean
on the road that says you're leaving
Jester Biel or welcome to Chesterfield
we have the same thing in Dallas there's
a little town called Frisco where it's a
hub of ultra rich people it's where the
athletes go live and whatnot and it's a
suburb of Dallas if you live in Dallas
Frisco is Dallas but if you live in
Frisco you live in Frisco right you
don't live in Dallas right exactly the
same [__] same [__] in Chesterfield
Missouri so
um now it's confusing because
um this 19 year old is of Indian descent
I believe and he was carrying a Nazi
flag now let me show you a post because
I was like ah these dumb [__]
man no wait they're already that's why
I'm so excited [__] what's that that's
why I was so excited to be on the show
with you today because these guys really
are are are are helping us out I mean
they really are these these these
non-white white supremacists are really
helping us out
um you know and you talked about that so
eloquently before and I just love the
fact that this is another
person of color
ing that white supremacy logo I loved it
man I love it because you got you got a
civil war going on in the proud boys
because you know those old school
hillbilly white boys from like where we
live right Mexicans aren't allowed
Cubans aren't allowed right damn sure
Indians aren't allowed you know what I
mean you know they you heard him say it
before they the racist names for him
from The Simpsons you know they they
they're not allowed in the club and
you've got that root in the proud boys
uh there's uh God I can't remember his
name Brian James Brian James he's having
a damn Civil War inside the proud boys
because he's like hey if it ain't white
it ain't right
and then they've got Enrique tario
running the thing and he's like that's
not white right so yeah the fact that
you get another and and like if you I
stay in touch with the Southern Poverty
Law said I'd say stay in touch I read
what they put out those are some sharp
guys
um they are talking about if they
haven't and you haven't read Poverty Law
Center just as a plug you should go
um read Poverty Law Center and some of
the stuff they put out because it's um
the the actual data that they scrape up
is is amazing again I don't I don't I
don't put data on people here but if you
want to go look at some extremely
terrifying data yeah the Southern
Poverty Law Center is really good
they're really good that's what they do
they track this [__]
you know and they've been discussing
this very thing that there's a civil war
a Schism breaking in the white supremacy
move because you know Universe
they're not gonna accept
you know Psy varshith can Doula as one
of their ranks they're just not that's
that's the crazy part Gabe Sanchez is
here Gabe um I I we um I I think I sent
this to you this morning this is Ryan
Cunningham he's a [__] Nazi
um and and only this tweet proves that
he is yeah I mean I've seen I've seen a
lot of these videos since last night
right so so here is the here's the truck
in in the location where it stopped
where these balliers stopped it
um from entering the space of the White
House um but you see on the ground here
you see that the Nazi flag and you see a
bunch of other uh possessions here that
they drug out of the truck again when
you rent a truck I don't know if anyone
knows this when you were in a truck
there's nothing in it there's not a
goddamn thing in it I mean you'd be
lucky you you'd be lucky to get any uh a
dolly if right exactly or or [__]
moving blankets at that but I mean see
anything that's in the truck is [__] you
put in the truck when you ran it right
so it's obvious here to me I mean this
is clearly they got the door open
they're searching through the truck
still they're laying the evidence that
they're finding in the truck out to take
pictures of it because they want to
fully document what the [__] in the
truck because once they determine
because I think there was several hours
where they were trying to determine
whether there was explosives in the
truck you know they're real careful
because this was obviously some sort of
threat um to our to National Defense
here when you're going after the White
House or in Washington DC in the first
place so they got to be really careful
they got to make sure there's no [__]
explosion devices no bombs in this thing
they got to make sure Marjorie Taylor
green isn't within the vicinity oh did I
say it out loud I'm sorry I'm Excuse me
um
I'm just saying pipe bomb pipe bomb pipe
bomb anyways anyways you don't want to
you don't you don't want to have
explosive devices in this thing and just
rummaging through it so that's the first
thing I'm going to do and then the other
thing they got to do is pull out all the
evidence of why the what motivated this
person to to try to Ram this thing into
the White House now here's what Ryan
Cunningham this [__] bonehead says
here's what he tweets he says an empty
box struts hits the barriers in front of
the White House at low speeds of course
they hit it at low speeds you dummy they
have to break through barriers to get to
the White House this isn't just an open
[__] door that a U-Haul truck can
drive through you've lost so have you
seen the video from the other angle no
well and we can if you want to pull that
out we can do that but here he says the
driver surrenders right okay the secret
servers service slash FBI conveniently
places evidence in a perfect camera
photo op yeah because they're taking
pictures of it you dumb son of a [__]
he says then they roll it up yeah
because it's evidence it's evidence
they're gonna they're gonna process it
you [__] [__] he said this is not
how you process evidence and they know
it this is exact it's exactly this is
exactly exactly how they process
everything you stupid bastard they take
pictures of it they they took pictures
of it in the truck they got it out got
it out on the ground to take pictures of
what it really was out of the truck on
the ground in on the crime scene at the
crime scene and then they're gonna roll
it up and take it in to the evidence
room it's not [__] complicated I said
here's what I said you false flag
[__] are dumber than dog [__] you
can clearly see that this is his
possessions he had in the rental truck
laid out to take evidence pictures when
you're defending a domestic Nazi
terrorist that makes you a Nazi
sympathizer which means you're uh Nazi
stop defending Nazis okay so it's also
weird because they say they they love
you know law enforcement they love the
cops and they love you know to back the
blue and then at the same time they're
like but uh that's not normal protocol
because I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about these are the people these
are the idiots that are like man I know
so well how to be a cop at what they do
everything from A to Z and it's like if
you would have known if you actually did
care and love them like you say you do
other than just use it as an excuse to
shoot people
you would know that when there's a scene
a crime an incident you take evidence
and there's a certain protocol there's a
procedure there is a there is a instead
of instructions that you have to follow
so that if you were to prosecute and
investigate this case further you don't
tank the evidence or screw up the case
for the goddamn prosecution
right and the one one of the best ways
Texas Paul one of the best ways to
collect evidence is not only to observe
the evidence
to um take pictures of it oh no no you
can't it's more important
but more importantly guys like say there
had been a Manifesto in there or
something like that they would not have
left it rolled up or however it ended up
whenever this thing hit that they're
going to take it they're going to lay it
on the ground and they're going to take
a picture of the manifesto where you can
see in the background exactly where they
are and when they are so that when this
goes to court they're going to tell
people this came with him here he had
this here when he committed the crime
this is stupid that they're trying to
say that this was Planet evidence this
is not how you collect everything
exactly this is this you got to remember
though this is the same group people who
looked at the photos from Mar-A-Lago and
said this evidence was planted even
though Donald Trump later said uh yeah I
took it it was mine I Declassified it it
was mine to take it was myself I know
but but when but when you when you hear
people this is a false flag this is all
planted and it's like but you got to
remember these are the same people that
said the evidence that had all the top
secret classified filings and covers on
them that were at Mar-A-Lago also said
it was planted and still believe it was
planted even after Trump said yeah I
took those things because I believed
that they were well here's the thing
they they know they know they know that
what this is the actual process they
have to say it's not because they have
to Gaslight their dumb [__] troll
Farms is what they have to do and they
gotta project what the troll Farms are
supposed to say as reply guys that way
when when people tweet the truth or talk
about the truth out in real life people
like no that's the full swag that's like
the Bud Light thing it's the same
[__] thing the target thing same
thing they have to Gaslight their
followers they have to show them because
their followers are dumb as they think
they're dumber than dog [__] I mean they
[__] make a mockery of dog [__] for
their supporters and their supporters
they got to give them the they gotta
feed them the lines Texas ball
and there are more pictures than this I
guarantee you one of the favorite
pictures that special agents take is
when they're hauling evidence out like
if they if they went in to bust a guy
for documents and he's got a grow Farm
in the back room there are pictures of
special agents holding up pots full of
weed and everything else laughing their
asses off they're asking the the the the
the the damn perp hey do me a favor take
a picture with this and he's in there
holding a thing I mean they have a good
time with this folks they really do
I guarantee you there's a picture of two
cops holding up that nasty flag right
next to that U-Haul
this stupid [__] you know it's crazy
ass [__] well here's the here's the
actual video and Gabe that you because
this is I mean again this isn't like in
a secluded area and it wasn't the middle
of the night or something there's people
on the street this is a recording of
someone's like what the [__] is going on
here and I'm sure that's what their
first thought is what the [__] is
happening here because this U-Haul truck
is obviously trying to pull in a place
where it doesn't belong and it and it's
not going to go through
um but watch watch the video here of the
U-Haul truck actually ramming into the
balliers or the barricades is
you see him oops
and again the the barriers that the
barricades did just what they were
supposed to do right and and what he was
doing is he was trying to break through
it what he doesn't understand is it's
just not the post above the ground right
this [__] thing is National Security
right this thing comes up from the
ground underneath and if you're also
going to assume like oh man it's just
these little PL these like uh these
little blockers or there's like a little
bit underneath or whatever it's like you
have to remember what this is outside of
okay we have the White House right so
you're this isn't just the first set of
barricades there's gonna be another set
of barricades down the road and another
one after that right and another one
after that like it's one of these each
one of these is like an iceberg right so
you see the tip of it but the bottom of
it's like you also but you have to
remember like physics and understanding
how that works isn't their strong suit
when they're like oh well I'm just gonna
Ram it and break it right as opposed to
understanding that there's Leverage
underneath the ground a concrete black
asphalt surface and you've got probably
18 to 20 feet of this pylon feet down
yeah 12 feet 12 feet deep and then it
goes up another I don't know four feet
five feet or whatever you're thinking
that you're gonna break that with your
U-Haul truck despite that you got the
like super large XL version
and you're also not ramming at full
speed you're going at something from you
know maybe like 12 feet away and then
deciding to go full speed accelerating
nah get the [__] out of here
and and and also it's like when you see
like a movie and then they yell cut and
then you see all the [__] in the
background just a little FYI when that
truck started to get anywhere near the
White House he was on camera he was
monitored when he pulled up to the White
House there were snipers on the roof of
the White House that uttered the words I
have the Target
and we're waiting he was waiting for his
Commander to say go so you wanna see you
want to see a great picture
of where this guy was at
um do you remember the guy who who was
on the red bike Joe flood he was yawning
screaming at Patriot front yeah yeah
last week he was mocking them which is
hilarious he took a picture this guy
because he's a photographer in DC and he
took a picture this is this is the
actual Ballard this is the damage that
the truck did to the barrier do you see
that mud oh my God it's almost like it
didn't even phase it
and again you see how far away like you
were saying Gabe how far away yeah the
actual White House is is from where it
is there are there are sections leading
up from this point closer to the White
House that there are there are uh there
are more uh
what are they called balliards I I would
I would guarantee that there are flat as
can be on on the ground and you wouldn't
know that you'd be like oh look it's
like one of those spotlights on the
ground and this thing [__] goes all
the way up yeah I guarantee there's
another two or three beyond that you
don't even see right right I gotta
I got a funny story for you just Rook I
promise it won't take more than a minute
my dumbass Uncle okay the switch it's
sweet man he really was a wonderful guy
but he was dumb as a pile of bricks he
really was but he was a sweet guy so
he's a truck driver okay he goes into DC
in the middle of the night he can't drop
his load so he's like well I'm gonna do
a little sightseeing and he's driving
around the White House with an 18
freaking wheeler going through all the
no trucks allowed signs all this other
[__] [__] PD is following him around
the center they finally pull him over I
mean he's gone to the monument the
Egyptian Memorial everything he's
driving around with an 80 foot 80 foot
of truck you know and they're like and
they pull up this guy's got bombs or
toilet paper in it and they they pull
them over and they're like yeah I just
been driving around doing some sights
even they're like we know we know let's
open the back of the truck genius
they gave him they gave him a ticket so
they took it easy on him because they
realized he was just a dumbass they gave
him a ticket that you've got the no
trucks allowed so you got a ticket for
that well and then you know that that
really happened
that's why that's why they that's why
when this U-Haul truck got anywhere
close to this site they they were
probably on to him immediately but
here's the thing is that
that your uncle's story they if they
open that truck they probably had to
break the seal and I bet he had to pay a
huge fine on his load because his seal
was broken when he got to his
destination I don't know if a lot of
people know I I bet they took it easy on
him because that was the funniest
freaking story if you knew my uncle Bert
he's just telling this story just
straight face like this is normal as
[__] man yeah I was just driving around
it's a beautiful place man I've never
been in DC before it's beautiful let me
ask you Texas Paul this is a serious
question about Uncle bird
he's dead well no I I mean sure what
does do you also have an Uncle
Ernie just wondering no no okay God damn
it that was gonna thicken the plot there
I don't know
um someone says Aunt Ernie
Chris was trying to beat me to it Chris
he's some [__] the audience is always
jumping on the jokes here they're the
funniest audience in the world
um someone was sending a message I just
got it I just got Bert and Ernie I just
got oh geez [__] Christ man are you
serious
are you serious oh [__] dude I thought
you were I thought you were up to speed
that's the first thing I thought of when
you said Uncle Ernie I thought our uncle
bird I was like there's got to be an uh
Uncle Ernie here as well someone was
sending a message here uh they wanted to
send us a message and someone's trying
to point it out
um it's from cruising for a blueskin
Blues in uh they said I really loved all
three of you guys I feel so strongly
that your efforts are making a
significant difference to say democracy
well we appreciate that
um but really it's us talking to you
and you and you taking that message and
engaging in democracy is what's really
saving it so
um where I as I say all the time I only
have one microphone you have thousands
so
um it's just uh here here's the comment
here I can bring it up uh so crucial for
blues and uh thank you very much and we
appreciate you coming and watching every
single day and tuning in and um carrying
the message with you that's that's the
intention of this show and a laugh
um when Texas Paul doesn't get the joke
about Burton Ernie that's you know also
the intention so there's there's another
story guys going around that um Jack
Smith oh my God I I don't I don't know
how like this isn't the top of the
[__] news
Jack Smith has subpoenaed Donald Trump's
Financial records with foreign entities
and foreign countries Texas Paul what do
you make of this so far with this news I
mean I thought about it I'm like how
does this have to do the documents case
and you start to and you start to put it
together you're like God damn Jack Smith
he's got a lot on this guy that's why
this is taking so [__] long is
because every time he overturns a rock
there's another goddamn crime don't you
think
Texas ball I I am Telling You Trump's
nuts are in a sling anytime you have an
investigation and you have obvious
foreign ties Gabe do you have any family
down in Mexico
if you ever fall under a federal
investigation okay they're going to
explore those ties they are yeah that's
yeah and that's what has Trump so
screwed about this and that's why the
people around him that actually have
brains have been having such a fit about
this because once you open that can of
worms every freaking thing that Donald
Trump has ever done is going to be
explored
microscopically by people that just love
to do nothing but crunch numbers I'm
telling you and you know they his ass is
in such a tight crack right now because
of the way he runs his business I'm
sorry I don't mean to laugh he just said
his ass is in a tight crack so I don't
know if his ass has a tight crack or
it's in a tight crack I don't know he's
caught in a tight crack I'm sorry he
can't get out he's
yeah the hilarious part about this is is
exactly what you said earlier in the
show if he had just shut the [__] up and
gone down to Mar-A-Lago a minute
defeating chilled out yep yeah laundered
his Russian money decided they wouldn't
have touched him because he was a former
president right they don't like to do
that because that sets a precedent
within the country of attacking the
previous administration and we don't do
that here that's one of the things to
keep things smooth to you we shouldn't
have to but in this case he's [__]
forced our hand he's forced yesterday I
mean just yesterday like we knew last
week there were there were Rumblings
from within aging Carol's team about
whether or not they were going to pursue
the defamatory comments that he made
during his little CNN town hall and then
yesterday we find out that they're like
yeah we're going to sue him again and
then now they're thinking well if the
last one was that 5 million and he was
found liable and then just two three
days later he has a CNN town hall and
says the same if not worse things about
her
you know I think it was uh George Conway
was on Chris Hayes last night was like
ah this is gonna be upward over 5
million I mean like some people are
talking about 10 million right like well
he's just gonna keep adding on to it
because the announcement of this news
this morning he started [__] typing
out on true social more defamation yeah
he just can't stop
um I'm gonna see if I can find that that
you you can't well yeah I mean we say it
all the time right like don't take the
shovel out of his hand like he's gonna
he can't help himself but say something
right he can't let someone and this is
the this is the absolute problem with
Donald Trump
he can never let anyone have the final
say
he has to say something after it even if
it even if it's nonsense it's it's uh
gibberish it's uh it's something that
gets him more in trouble right the thing
that is most important about Donald
Trump is the way that his mind works is
he has to have the final say he has to
want to be like oh you fired I owned you
you got it you're done whatever it might
be
he's going to do it to himself
and that's obviously on him and you know
by all means keep doing it because uh
you're doing a [__] bang-up job oh
yeah killing it you're killing it man
here's here's his here's his defamatory
statement towards EG and Carol this
morning he says I don't I don't know e
Gene Carroll yeah okay I never met her
okay or touched her yeah okay he said
except on a celebrity line with her
African-American husband who she
disgustingly called the ape all right I
wouldn't know to know or touch her I
never abused her or raped her or took
her to a dressing room 25 years ago in a
crowded Department Store where the doors
were locked I don't know why he did that
he has no idea she has no idea when or
did anything else to her except deny her
fake made up story that she wrote in a
book it never happened it's total scam
unfair trial so he's still defaming her
still to this day again he cannot help
himself he has to be the last one to say
something that's crazy my impression of
Trump's lawyers after reading that this
morning
ah this is just what Gabe said and and I
I think there's a motion that there's
not motion for new trial in a new case
this is she went to they're going to the
judge and saying hey you awarded us this
amount of money for this defamation he's
continuing to do the same defamation we
want more money because he continues to
do this thing that he's convicted of now
so we want more so I I and I don't know
what the wall is exactly I'm not a
[__] lawyer but it feels like to me
that Eugene Carroll's lawyers are saying
hey we're just gonna keep asking for
money if he keeps the famous they didn't
even ask for money the first time around
right like that was something they they
didn't say oh this is what we're seeking
in Damages it was like we're just
looking for acknowledgment that the guy
did what I said he did despite the fact
that he's defaming me out in public uh
you know especially during in 2019
during his presidency
and then the jury was like all right we
award her 5 million which of course you
know Donald Trump's legal team is going
to uh they're going to argue that and
they're going to peel it and all that
stuff
but it's almost like they couldn't I
don't even know if they got the appeal
submitted before Donald Trump said the
[__] that he said and they're like oh
[__] okay well we can't even appeal
it now because he [__] said even more
you know and it's it's every every case
he's involved in you know Gabe you're
right on the money every case he's
involved in his attorneys are swigging
down Maalox like it's you know I mean
freaking Maylock Shooters lined up on
the desk man
because every time this guy touches a
keyboard I mean he cannot shut up well
here you go I mean that's the first
thing every two here's one since we've
been on the air this is [__] insane
man listen to this he he he actually
typed this [__] out this whiny little
[__] he says so Dominion gets almost a
billion dollars and I
after years of fake news hoax scams and
investigations and entitled to nothing
question mark is that really the way
it's supposed to work I don't think so
no dude that's exactly how it works
that's exactly how it works they're not
fake it's not fake news it's not hoax
it's not scams and yes there are
investigations because you're a [__]
criminal so you're entitled to
indictments okay and you're entitled
entitled to judgments that make you pay
aging Carol for the defamation that you
continue to do that's exactly exactly
how it works in the real world I know
Grandpa that you have felt your whole
life that you were Above the Law and
there's nothing that can touch you
because you are an elite and you are
entitled and you're the one percent
which you're not it's all fake it's all
[__] but I know that you feel like
there's a two-tier justice system and
there is one and the two-tier justice
system is no longer protecting you
that's why you're mad that's why you're
upset [__] so get used to it the
craziest part about it all
to that these people are like this is
our guy like you're like what the [__]
how the F you people are so [__] mind
[__] how could you be so mind [__]
to believe that this is your guy how why
what the [__] is it you but the the big
problem is you also have to realize that
Republicans are these Maga cultists
whatever you want to call them they are
so invested time money energy like
they've alienated every other single
person who has a working brain and has
you know functioning logic where now
they're the only ones who have you know
they've they've
they they've allowed they've
impressingly allowed themselves to
alienate themselves from everyone else
in existence and Society to to
self-identify say I've got the Maga hat
I love Trump and this is what I'm going
to believe right but the thing you have
to realize is that if they were to admit
the reality that exists right now that
Donald Trump did defraud his uh his
supporters he did lie about this he did
steal these documents he did try to
um you know overturn the election he did
try to do these things all these illegal
things he did you know rape e Gene
Carroll like whatever it might be if
they accept one truth
then they have to accept the next truth
and the next truth and the next truth
and oh so it's like it's like a it's
like a truth Avalanche then is what
you're saying yeah and a little bit here
a little bit there and it turns yeah
it's like basically like if you were to
you know they were like oh man you got
to take the red pill get get woke and
you got all this [__] wake up and all
this [__] and see see the Matrix and
it's like
you know in that movie in the scene
we're like oh my God like I'm now
realizing everything I was was just
simulation these people would go through
this same thing but imagine if you were
to spend six plus years believing this
guy feeding him money defending him and
fighting for him and committing crimes
for him
that all of a sudden you're like oh [__]
the the implosion that would happen
within one person's brain to be like oh
my God this world I've been living has
been a [__] yeah but they know what
don't you think no I don't think that
they all know that well here's here's a
great tweet by um Mueller she wrote
she's rewarding this morning on this
Wall Street Journal um uh report that
Jack Smith is all but finished with the
documents probe which doesn't mean he's
closer to indictments it just means he's
uncovered all the rocks on the documents
part of it no telling what other rocks
he's overturned but it says she says
breaking sources tell the Wall Street
Journal Jack Smith is all but finished
with the documents probe here's the most
important part of the tweet and I think
you just were talking about how the
money's tied to this thing and by money
I mean the grift she she says and the
people in Trump's orbit are beginning to
plan how to fundraise off Trump's
indictments they're like okay he's gonna
get indicted we know he's going to be
the nominee so how are we going to raise
money on this like that's their their
mind doesn't go dude this guy shouldn't
be our [__] leader they're like how
we gonna grift off this like it's
[__] insane to me yeah it's insane to
me do you remember Texas Paul in the
late 90s when it when when Bill Clinton
was accused getting a [__] from an
intern in the Oval Office they couldn't
talk about anything else I mean they
wanted him to be in prison for the rest
of his life
for what Monica Lewinsky did to him or
what he did Kavanaugh by the way yeah
Brett Kavanaugh that's what they wanted
they wanted him in prison they wanted
him gone they wanted Hillary in prison
they wanted anyone who was tied to Bill
Clinton prison over a [__] now here
we are here we are 2023 not but 25 years
later almost 25 years later
and here we are and we can't we can't
even get these people to go yeah he he
seemed pretty crooked to me nope not
even [__] a smidge they're like [__]
it let's just raise money off of it I
mean but that's there's no there's no
way to go
other than that right other than down
the only way I mean like it's one of
those things where like um
like you know if you have a business
you're like oh well the only way is to
raise more capital and hopefully to get
past this hole that I'm in right I've
gotta get more to fill this hole to then
get more to fill that hole and then get
more to fill this hole like they they
continue to work off this premise of
like this guy will drive traffic I can
make money off this guy but only because
they've learned from that very guy right
his own I'm a victim and I'm I'm the one
being wrongfully persecuted and this is
all political hack and it's a it's a
Witch Hunt and all this you know
whatever they want to say
but they've learned from this very guy
who's who complains non-stop if anything
ever goes wrong if it ever doesn't go
his way right if the last thing he says
gets him in more trouble like we've seen
he says they're attacking me I was just
telling the truth and it's like yeah you
might have been telling the truth but
you were also admitting to the crimes
that you did doesn't mean that you're
the victim
it's just every every chance they get
they will try to make money off of it
and that's just now their default
strategy go ahead because I got some
news I want to share but go ahead and
give us your thoughts on that it
highlights the difference between
liberals and conservatives you know they
like to call us sheep but I want you to
imagine for one second that news broke
that on my phone in a criminal
investigation
me sitting with you on the Tony Michaels
show was texting you that the people
that are sitting in this audience right
now
I called them cousin [__]
now imagine that news breaking
they would be gone our cousin [__]
audience they would be called Fox News
in court documents one of their
producers that worked for Tucker Carlson
called The Fox News audience cousin
[__]
but what Gabe is exactly saying the
cognitive dissonance the way they can
separate themselves these people would
know hey this this guy's full of [__]
he's an [__] they would nail it right
away because we're liberals we think we
don't just follow willy-nilly we don't
do that
these people on the right were literally
called cousin [__] by one of their
Heroes
total denial didn't happen it was
planted I mean literally saw Teresa said
the feds made that up
and it's amazing I mean Gabe hit it
right on the head I mean you nailed it I
mean these people are so lost well
that's that's a feature of the of the
cult and a cult and that's why I keep
saying Trump's going to win because
that's how Colts work on speaking of
cults
hell the fascist in Florida
um has propelled that state into a
dismal situation but do you remember
um a poet a great American poet oh my
God if you you guys watch the the Biden
inauguration Amanda Gorman
going to be in history known and I know
she is because she's only like and she's
only like 19 or something she's really
young yeah she's moving down and she's
she's one of the best poets when she
gave that speech it was so inspiring I
was like this is what America is going
to be this is what America is going to
look like is Amanda Gorman and they are
[__] mad about it and it excites me
that she is the future of America she is
the future of what America is going to
look like
well guess what in Florida
they want to ban books this morning
um the the poem that was read I'm going
to read this the poem that was read by
poet
Amanda Gorman at President Joe Biden's
inauguration has been banned from
elementary schools in Miami-Dade County
Florida after the objections of just one
parent listen to this the Miami Herald
reports that the poem which is titled
quote the hills we climb that's the poem
that she read and she wrote and she
performed that's the way I see it after
the inauguration it was beautiful not
just the poem itself but how she
delivered it it says was removed from K
through five curriculum in the county
after local parent
um daily Salinas challenged it as
inappropriate for students wholly actual
[__] okay folks I don't know if you know
um how Nazis work but this is how it
works
you can go read the [__] poem If
you're mad if you're mad about the hills
we climb the poem and talking about how
far we've come in this country and how
far we can go with inspiration and you
think that is inappropriate for children
to read you are the dumbest [__] Nazi
I have ever seen in my [__] entire
life and frankly for for them to even
consider this
for them to even consider this is
[__] the quiet part out loud she's
black she's an American poet and she's
talking about progress she's talking
about Liberty in this [__] speech in
this poem not only not only that but
like you also have to realize that yeah
she's you know a well-renowned poet but
also graduated Harvard [__] laude so like
not you also have an educated woman an
educated bipoc woman right there's a
there's a huge threatening sign that's
like trigger trigger trigger that's
going off in in Republicans heads we
can't have someone of color we can't
have someone who's a woman we can't have
someone who's Highly Educated we can't
have someone who is well known we can't
have someone who is well respected all
of these things this Venn diagram
there's a [__] blinking sign that's
like get trigger get trigger get
triggered she's gonna come for you you
know this is she's gonna convert your
children they're gonna this is the same
it's like it's the same thing with like
oh the beer's gonna turn me gay reading
having drag queens reading to read into
my children gonna turn them into trans
kids like that's not at all how that
[__] works you walk in a tar hey you
walk in a Target apparently you got to
get out your gate card right apparently
anytime anytime clothing has anything
from a rainbow if you see colors if you
see it you turn gay right you turn gay
as soon as you see it Texas but this is
this is them right they are afraid and
what they're afraid of they try to
silence and they try to surprise and
they try to remove it and they think one
mother for whatever her racist reasons
are says I don't like this poem because
of XYZ right
and then you know [__] Miami-Dade you
know education's like yep okay sounds
good to us and you're like I'm sorry
what do we what are we actually
accomplishing here what are we doing
that's supposed to be actually you know
for the betterment of humankind for the
betterment of [__] Florida Texas this
is why I say we lean the [__] into this
we lean into this heart I get
tweets from my Governor all the time
saying parents know best about their
kids education
no the [__] you don't
no you don't you are not educated enough
and I'm talking to everybody you are not
a skilled educator you cannot develop
curriculums for your child you can't
that's why when you want to homeschool
you go to one of these online courses
that lays out a curriculum for you Karen
because you cannot develop a curriculum
for your kids you can't it's that simple
so the next time one of you dumb cousin
[__] [__] like Rhonda santis
tries to tell me parents know best
parents should have the input in our
schools parents should sit the [__] down
and show up for PTA meetings and field
trips and help their goddamn
professional Educators educate your in
great stupid spoiled kids that's what
should happen
uh sorry
oh my God
the Nature Boy Texas poem
right like right he is parents who can't
be bothered to send an email back to a
teacher who can't be bothered to show up
to a parent-teacher conference who can't
be bothered to even show up to a bake
sale to help their class fundraise for
whatever resources they they can get
because the state decided to pull
funding right if they can't be bothered
to do any of those things to help their
children like where's the whole you
should have a say in terms of just
saying oh here's a basic education we're
not trying to turn your kids gay turn
your kids trans we're not trying to
bring that into school it's like shut
the [__] up man no one's doing that [__]
but if you can't be bothered to play a
part in your child's education by just
doing those simple things answering a
phone sending an email back to a teacher
whatever it might be then you're
complaint of I want my parental rights
back you don't have a [__] save
because you didn't do anything to begin
with
they're saying you're bringing the heat
Texas Paul and this next story should
bring some more heat
this is dumber than Doug [__] I mean I
don't know how else to [__] describe
it
speaking of dumb parents Margaret Taylor
green
um this morning apparently in a
republican Caucus meeting
paid a hundred thousand dollars for this
piece of chapstick here I want to know
was it her money or was it uh campaign
money I have no idea apparently they
auctioned this uh lipstick or chapstick
excuse me I don't want to get it
confused I don't want to confuse these
[__] Republicans that don't know the
difference between lipstick and jam
stick but this uh chapstick that is uh
Aaron Bean
um um campaign chapstick it's like merch
right or a giveaway yeah it's used by
Kevin McCarthy apparently and this
morning they had a 15-minute auction to
auction off this piece of chapstick that
was um
um used I I guess by Kevin McCarthy I
don't know I think that would make it
less valuable to be quite honest it's
trash at that point but Marjorie Taylor
green bid a hundred thousand dollars
um on this um on this chapstick that was
used by Kevin McCarthy and and we're
supposed to believe they're not a cult
are you kidding me what the [__] is what
the hell is this [__] so she paid money
yeah and she took covered money 180
Grand in covered money so she used she
she used uh chapstick that we used on
Kevin McCarthy's [__] well and then
bought it it is that what I'm
understanding it could I mean his mouth
his [__] is there a difference I'm
just saying like when you
you know I'm just I'm asking questions
here I'm asking
Kevin McCarthy's [__] so I wouldn't
be surprised if that was used on his
[__] I just want to know
like the fact that I I have so many
[__] questions where the money came
from I heard the money went
how this even came up like are they that
desperate for money well I think it was
a fundraiser so they're trying to reason
what well because I'm raising what
because they're they're out of money and
they gotta fundraise from their main
fundraiser which is Marjorie Taylor
green the only reason why this sludge is
still in the Republican caucus is
because
is this is this something well I mean I
guess so I get well between campaign and
campaign because campaigns can give
other campaigns money like Mayo Mayo
points out a good point here she says
here's another clue for the FBI the DC
bomber loves the Chapstick I don't know
that could be a clue I don't know I mean
it's amazing follow the trail you know
make sure follow the Chapstick follow
the Chapstick instead of following the
money and follow the Chapstick I don't
know man Margaret Taylor agree man her
you know her boyfriend her right-wing
boyfriend Brian Glenn you know he's a
drag queen but also he's a supporter of
strippers though now now you know you
know they're they're these what
patriotic what the [__] yeah hold on let
me find it patriotics keeps uncovering
the [__] on Brian Glenn it's pretty
funny okay Texas ball I I don't mean
that because we're we're in the bottom
of the second area instead of those
stories I want to talk about one of them
speaking of losers
big manga losers apparently Carrie Lake
really thought that this the state was
going to overturn uh a dually elected
governor maker Governor just be like
yeah you're the governor
and do that apparently they're not
they're not going to do that
um this was her last stand and not only
did the judge dismiss this case but the
judge dunked it in the [__] trash and
said not only do you not have a case
this is the dumbest thing I've ever seen
in my life basically and you're not
making a case at all because what you're
doing is telling lies there's no
evidence of what you're saying you're
lying you're lying to try to try to
steal away the office of the governor so
tell us what your take is and and if if
there's any I believe you just missed it
I believe you dismissed it with
prejudice so that's it I mean she's done
she is done and no I don't think she
believes she had a snowball's chance in
hell in this case I really don't I do
believe that she took a lot of people's
money a lot of idiots out there a lot of
[__] dreamers these these these right
wing you know same people you were
talking about just a second ago there
Gabe those same people were cutting her
checks for her legally learned it
defense from the best that's true yeah
one she's been doing it with the best
because she's been really powering
around with uh Steve Bandon on his
traitor TV News Network she's been
really going down to Mar-A-Lago and
selling this [__] line that she's
actually the governor
um I I think she was trying to get a
place on the ticket but I actually you
know Carrie Lake said this in one of the
spaces we're in a lot and Mario's spaces
she was in the space
um she actually said something that I
thought I was like hey she's onto
something she's saying something out
loud that is the quiet part she said
Texas Paul that she doesn't believe
Donald Trump needs a running mate and I
actually don't think he's going to
select a running mate I know that sounds
crazy people like how is that even
possible like I he does [__] that
doesn't make sense right I don't think
he's gonna have to he can appoint the
vice president when he becomes president
he doesn't have to run with him so I
actually believe he's gonna run without
a vice president and the reason why is
because he doesn't want someone out
there talking about him and have to
answer for his [__] crimes that's
that's not something they want so I
actually believe that Donald Trump is
going to run alone on the ticket not
with anyone and Carrie Lakes onto
something there here's Mark Elias's uh
tweet about um the breaking news on the
Arizona Court he says breaking Arizona
Court rejects Cara Lake's last legal
challenge this is the last one in the
state
um to the 22 uh election for governor
courts confirmed quote the election of
Kerry Hobbs as Arizona governor so not
only do they confirm that yes Kerry Lake
lost but Katie Hobbs is the actual
Governor the duly elected governor it's
in it's in there confirming right see
it's ordered it is ordered Last Stand
confirming the election of Gideon's
Governor that's it now I guess Kerry
Lake could decide to try to take this to
the Supreme Court it's not going to do
any good because I hope she does I hope
so well yeah it would be great rate
stepping but I actually think that that
won't go anywhere in the U.S District
Courts
um they'll reject it on its Merit
because they're like wait we can't
overturn a state election that's not
also they'll look at everything else
that was aside and be like everyone else
said this [__] is [__]
the case
normally an appeal is is almost
automatic in most cases but this is not
going to be one of those cases right I
believe that they're just going to
reject it they're not they're going to
refuse to hear it right
anyone I think anyone who looks at it is
going to laugh at it and be like are you
serious you you really want to you
really want to submit this well no I'm
sorry I'm not going to waste my time I'm
not gonna waste my colleagues time I'm
not going to waste the people who have
to [__] file the dockets all that
[__] I'm not going to waste anyone's
time for this
some people are saying that this is the
87th time that Kerry lake has lost as
the governor's race
this is the 87th time she's lost the
governor he's probably the final time
she'll lose the governor race how many
times do you got a [__] lose to just
be like okay I lost I'm a loser like how
many times it doesn't exist and I'll
tell you what's hilarious about those
Republicans in Arizona is they're making
themselves look like complete [__] I
don't know if you've heard the latest on
on the whole uh voter registration thing
they're trying to say that there were 9
000 Republicans whose registration was
denied in this state
Carrie Hobbs wasn't Governor when that
happened for one thing second
these are the same people that were
running signature checks these are the
same people that were actually actively
working to deny people's registration
and now they're turning around and
trying to say too many registrations
were denied we got to fix this we've got
to do this but but but
only in this one area where there's a
lot of Republicans
we want to deny registrations other
places we're just talking about this one
specific area like where strip clubs are
are or something I don't know I'm trying
to transition to the strip club story I
haven't watched this clip back man these
clips are wild man so this is a clip of
a drag queen
um not to be confused um the drag queen
is the the guy this is this is this is
Margaret Taylor Green's show it's called
Uh MTG yeah uh Battleground episode
the man is the one on the left
yes it might take you a moment if you
like wake up in the morning this looks
like they woke up they're in her
backyard and you know he's I'm sure the
kids are really loving Brian Glenn
showing up there for breakfast right but
this is them I would imagine the
backyard doing some [__] interview he
was also just on her show the other day
as well in like the little Studio oh
yeah he was he was he was trying to talk
about how Jamal Bowman was yeah
aggressive they're like you're not
racist she's like I don't know Emmett
Till is important and it's like okay
here's Gonna Save that but doesn't mean
you believe it here's the thing here's
the thing I would love I would love for
charity for Brian Glenn and Jamal Bowman
to have a boxing match that would be
[__] awesome wouldn't it oh yeah
let's do that hey Brian get in the
charity ring and let's see you defend
your I just whatever it is Jamal
Bowman's face just [__] Paul Ryan
Glenn's face just hold him as he swings
you're right let's not let's not do a
boxing match let's do like full-on UFC I
want to see Blood let's do Bloodsport
with this one for the people that don't
know that haven't been following this
whole Jamal Bowman thing if you remember
back and think on the news there was a
big story on the news about this really
nice guy that was just walking through a
bird park in New York and he was doing
some birding he was looking around he
came across this black this white Karen
uh they had a she had a dispute he
wasn't even having a dispute fortunately
he recorded did all of it and then she
calls the police and says this man is
threatening me I'm so scared there's a
black man here he's in the park while
back yeah that is exactly what Marjorie
Trader green the elevator flatulator
just did to Jamal Bowman oh yeah they
had they had words he basically told her
she could go [__] herself
and now she's trying to swat Jamal
Bowman by saying he threatened me he was
he was he was talking to me while black
and he may have
so let's see here this clip that Gabe
sent me this is about strip clubs Gabe
I'm excited that it's about it in strip
clubs and then we play the clip after
this that you know Brian Glenn the
hypocrite so okay let's let's listen now
this is probably one of the next one I I
don't know what to say but I remember
seeing this in the news adult
entertainment strip clubs if you will
gentlemen's club we're still well they
were still no gentlemen it was more of a
drive-through experience where you stay
in your car and I guess women are up on
uh little you know little little stages
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait where the [__] are these
drive-through strip clubs in
I don't know man how far do I have to
drive to get to one of these I'm just
saying are you kidding me
are you [__] serious
Gabe I'm asking you specifically because
you happen to be the nicest sweetest guy
on this show man
you're as bad as I am Tony okay
you we've got to drive through Daiquiri
stands down here in the South we've got
the drive-through beer Shacks down here
in the South now we could just complete
the trifecta with the drive-through
strip club you know you just hit the you
hit you hit the Dr The Daiquiri stand
get you a nice Frozen fruity and then
you drive through the strip club get it
all done my question is I don't know how
you hit the hit the tips in but actually
I might I might say that the real
Trifecta is you get your alcohol you get
a daiquiri or beer you go to the strip
club right you enjoy a show yeah and
then you go through a drive-through car
wash boom clean ready to go and you head
home that's a good idea a full drink
show and then and a wash after I had no
idea that these existed is it just a
coveted thing because we shouldn't it
I didn't I didn't know this again visit
until this glimp but I think it was just
purely a covered thing oh okay well they
should that's one thing we should not
have stopped because of but let's listen
to how they feel about the everyone
knows how I feel I guess now about
drive-through strip clubs let's find out
how Marjorie Taylor green and her her
new drag queen feels about it uh doing
their thing
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous to begin
with I'm gonna say this is one of the
things that that kovid should have shut
down and kept shut down as strip clubs
and the Very fact that wait wait a
second hang on a second hang on aren't
these the people who said that it's
against Liberty and freedom to shut down
businesses on covid that it's an
infringement on our rights and all this
[__] that churches and gyms and
restaurants and all this stuff at the
stakeholder what the [__] are they
talking about are they anti-bus it makes
me feel like these are just fascists who
are just just making sure that churches
stay open so that they can they can
breed their fascism to their sheep
followers and has nothing to do with
business or Freedom or Liberty at all
what the [__] am I crazy it just I don't
know maybe I'm nuts Texas Paul am I nuts
no no it's it's hypocrisy it's hypocrisy
I do have to come out and say this folks
don't go to strip clubs strippers don't
love you any more than Donald Trump
it's the same group
damn don't listen to him audience make
sure to support your local strip clubs
there it's very important to these
people so I will say I will say I'm
actually I'm actually uh very very
excited to see how this moves forward
but here in North Hollywood yeah uh
there was a there's a strip club that
actually formed a union
really uh-huh hey I'm all for that too
so now it's great because they were like
look with the security isn't safe and
this isn't up to date and this and that
and so it sounds like you know this
could be the starting of uh that's great
of unionizing yeah let's do it all
around the country benefits hell yeah
services and better conditions all
around listen I'm actually the belief
and I know Texas Paul I know you're just
joking because sex workers work rather
it's actually sex or you're using using
uh the Allure of sex to do work and earn
money I think sex workers work and we
should we should respect those people we
should give those people protections
from [__] sickos like this let's
continue to see what they else they see
derogatory about sex workers I've had
forced the sherpers out in public where
it becomes Jesus Christ uh that is
Apollo to me I wish covet had shut down
all strip clubs oh my God okay that's
the woman says the woman yeah who had
affairs with her husband one of which
was with a tantric sex guru a word that
self that's self that's Proclamation
and also uh one of the the trainers at
the gym right so it's like she's she's
not for someone performing on a pole but
she's the same person who will perform
CrossFit then have sex I don't you're
just like is this like one of those
things well yeah Gabe it's perfectly
acceptable to get bent over at your gym
man I mean come on you know I mean
there's no money changing hands she did
that for free
well hey speaking of hypocrisy I just
noticed there's there's another video
here yeah that's what I'm saying oh okay
so so there's another video here and
apparently uh Marjorie Taylor Green's
new drag queen
um once said that strippers could be
considered therapists guess what guess
what there is there's [__] video
evidence of this let's take a listen you
could consider male strippers therapists
who don't charge by the hour they just
get tipped per day I've got the right
outfit for this but I got to be
completely honest with you for dance
party Thursday I'm ridiculed when I go
out in public it's like dude we laugh at
you you got no skill when it comes to
dancing can you take an average guy like
myself and give me a few you know I'm
really famous for the lawnmower kind of
move no but that's not a little while
ago yeah but can you show an average guy
like me I can go I can go out and say
you know what I think I can kind of be a
Thunder from Down Under okay so not only
is he a drag queen he's a [__] didn't
want to be stripper too yep what the
actual [__] is going on what the f why
why why in the [__] do they do this [__]
you know audience one let me tell you
something real quick before you guys are
smart the reason why I'm authentic the
reason why I say the [__] I say and
sometimes it may hurt some people's
feelings and they may not like it it's
because I'm trying to be authentic
I'm trying to be authentic I'm trying
I'm trying to be authentic because I
don't want to be accused of being
something that I'm not or that I was or
wasn't and wasn't now and I can't
explain it so I just try to be who the
[__] I am that's it this is it you
getting the wrong real roll me right
maybe a little extra for the show maybe
just a little but this is me this is me
and this is the reason why [__]
you're this guy in [__] Walmart I
know you Tony I know you you are this
guy in [__] Walmart
I am I truly am I I don't well you can
see him in the freezer section he's
looking at the french fries they don't
have the big bag of fries what the [__]
is this Hey listen
all the damn french fries hey you you
fatty in the Maga hat I want your French
fries
it is me I was at karaoke a couple weeks
ago and I went to the bar to order a
shot of Jager right this is and this is
what happened and there was a guy
sitting down from the bar and he he
apparently knew who I was and I was
supposed to know who he was right and he
said he didn't remember my name we had
met several weeks earlier and another
like a live event with music and I and I
I was acquaintances with his wife to
introduced us I didn't I recognized him
but didn't know he was
he's called them from the from the end
of the bar and he said hey little bit
and I said what the [__] did you just
say to me he said oh I'm reside I said a
little bit and I said what the [__] are
you talking about and he said he said no
man I and the bartender who I was
acquainted with said hey that's my
husband I said Oh Aaron okay now I now I
remember now I remember I I'm I was like
I'm gonna kick your [__] ass
who the [__] are you and why are you
calling me little bit I don't think
that's a good idea friend and it was
just it was a funny exchange because
that is truly who I am I I don't give a
[__] this is authentic Gabe Sanchez can
tell you that uh for sure this is
exactly who I am and how I act I may
have been drunk on a few calls even
before very important calls I may have
had to mute and turn the camera off
to go get rid of some alcohol just just
because it was um it was necessary at
that point I can't I just don't
understand why these people try to be
something that they're not why do they
do that why because they do that because
they're nothing to begin with oh and if
they have nothing to start with and they
don't have a platform and they don't
have an outrage to get people riled up
about then they're nothing right they're
irrelevant so they have to be angry and
[__] and moan about this problem make a
big deal out of something you got to go
after Bud Light and probe them from a
big government standpoint because you
literally have nothing else going on in
your life that or rather nothing else to
represent your constituents or or no
other issues that you should be fighting
or or proposing or whatever it might be
you have to say
because I have nothing I'm I'm a blank
blank slate there's nothing interesting
about me I'm super [__] boring
they have to make stuff up they have to
lie about something and then of course
it comes out later that it's you know
revealed that days had the opposite
belief or they said it's all [__]
and it's all [__] it's all a [__]
facade
it seems like that's that's their
personality you can just make the
Assumption all right we'll just do this
you can just make the assumption that if
Republicans said something they've also
said the complete opposite or they
believe the complete opposite right and
I'm sure you know Democrats do the same
thing obviously like you know
politicians are politicians but
Republicans start from Ground Zero which
is they have nothing interesting about
themselves they are they are a know
nothing nobody
and then they tell lies and stories that
are later debunked or disproven
about how they are the complete opposite
right or they don't really believe those
things wait I have breaking news I have
breaking news
um and it's appropriate that this is on
Taco Tuesday with Texas phone here slim
jim is trending
um
what this is important [__] man this is
important I'm not eating another one of
those [__]
slim jim is is trending I'm not sure why
I'm trying to figure it out here but
apparently it has something to do with
Amanda Gorman no not oh I see
Florida band Slim Jims are you what what
the [__] is this isn't that Florida's
like main source of protein I I would
imagine I would imagine so
yeah you remember Macho Man Randy Savage
I just feel like that's uh like why
would it be banned was it woke did they
do something did they have a campaign
that was too woke I have no idea you
know what's crazy is in there in our
commercial
in our commercial break that we played
the um uh the trucker Convoy it talks
about Slim Jims and Natty light in there
oh man I'm so disappointed that it was
Natty not Bud Light at this point if
Slim Jims is actually something that
they're going after because it's woke
that would be [__] fantastic but
apparently they're banned in Florida I
don't know it's trending and it's
trending like number number [__] 10
in the United States I'm not [__]
you here let me show you I'm just I
don't want anyone to get confused and
I'm not trying to trick Texas Paul or
Gabe Sanchez into eating a slim jim
um cheese taco again but I just can't
where do you see anything I no one here
see what you going to it look here and
you go down here's the here's the thing
and it says what the [__] is wrong with
Florida
let's start with what's not banned
influence
reading Tony very important I feel like
maybe you should we should have a drag
queen Story Hour and we can teach you
how to read it could be listen I I was
so excited about slim jim trending
I was so excited I'm like there's
nothing on this thing about anything I
was so [__] excited about Slim Jim's
trending because
a Texas Paul tricked my ass into
thinking that a [__] slim jim toggle
would be good do you remember this
audience um
I said I will not I will not taint my
taste buds with something that I know is
disgusting Texas Paul ate one and he was
like oh it's delicious it's delicious so
the next week I ate one and it was
[__] disgusting it's [__] gross he
[__] tricked me into eating that son
of a [__] although I did kind of trick
him into eating it um to begin with but
oh my God okay I think that was the only
time you've ever talking to me talk to
me in actual anger Tony is I [__]
tested
[__] I was gonna kick his ass I
was gonna drive down to get Texas and
kick his ass for tricking me into eating
that [__] okay let's see that thing oh
yeah this is delicious man yeah it's
delicious [__] fantastic you should
try it Tony make sure you eat the whole
thing on air and [__] like that come on
man some [__] even though I started
it so I guess I deserve what I got you
know I started the whole thing
um southern strategy is is trending as
well
um I don't know what that's about well I
know it's Southern strategies about but
I'm not sure why it's running Matt Walsh
is also trending and I'm just trying to
find if there's any more hamburger Mary
let me talk about that for a second that
is a big [__] deal that is a burger
much bigger deal yeah it was trending on
Twitter hamburger Mary
I am telling you guys all this [__] that
DeSantis is doing is about to go down in
flames and you can thank drag queens for
doing it
tell us it's a very popular Burger Joint
down in Florida they've apparently got
great burgers
and they do a show every once in a while
at night with bread
Queens transgender folks come out and
dance and perform among the audience
and people love it they absolutely love
it well that's illegal now in Florida
so if they filed suit they've got
backers that they're going to take the
Supreme Court and this is going to shred
[__] putting fingers [__] because
you can't do this
you cannot do this these people have the
right to put on the show that they want
to put on the show and this has teeth
Tony it really does have to eat they're
an operating business
that makes their living with a drag show
that is not there's nothing dirty about
it there's nothing anything these are
professional performers and they're
gonna kill it man I'm really proud of
these folks well that's that's fantastic
when I live there really Hamburger
Mary's huh now I want to go to one of
these [__] places where's the closest
one to me I want to know I hear they're
great I've never been to one but I hear
they're great there isn't one around
here
um so they're so they're suing uh
DeSantis over drag shows and they are
lento Orlando are they saying because
it's a part of their business uh well I
would imagine that that's what they're
suing for yeah um I mean I I don't have
I mean what happens man you know like
speaking of DeSantis um there's one more
clip I want to show that I found this
morning very interesting uh Jason
Chaffetz do you remember Jason Chaffetz
is you remember this [__] he
he's like oh I've been gassy been gassy
Benghazi and then and then he didn't
want to lose his eye definitely narrows
it down Tony from every Republican out
there but yeah well okay [__] you man
okay so Jason japitz he's a former
congressman from Utah that there is that
help uh yeah yeah he's actually the guy
he was the first [__] I don't
know if you guys remember this but as
soon as the [__] grab and tape came out
Jason japitz was the first one on
[__] national news and he was saying
I'm not voting for Donald Trump I
condemn this he was the first one to it
and like two weeks later he's like well
I've kind of thought about it and you
know it's not that bad to assault women
by grabbing them by the genitals it was
really weird it was really weird because
he said he wasn't because of it and then
he said he was because it you know
whatever because no one else kind of
thought so that's Jason Chaffetz okay
again it sounds like every other
Republican you know lawmaker out there
wow
not to be confused um he spells Jason
correctly not Jason with a Y like Lauren
bobert's uh penis showing ex-hus are
confused to be ex-husband right but
Jason chaffet's here a former Utah
Congressman says this on Fox news about
Casey DeSantis there was a story about
Casey DeSantis none and he's really mad
he's really mad that people are going
after people's spouses but listen to the
end of it when he gets challenged on it
this is [__] hilarious watch
absolutely fundamentally top to bottom
wrong to go after Casey DeSantis again
like Tim Scott I served in congress with
Ron DeSantis I sat on Judiciary and
oversight for years with them I know her
she's a cancer survivor beautiful woman
mother of two she is nothing but an
asset and shame on the media for coming
after the family so quickly that is the
disgusting underbelly do they ever do
this to the Democrats do they ever do
this to the Democrats watch this this is
[__]
they talk about the Obama kids oh my God
watch this is beautiful this is on Fox
News remember this is on Fox [__]
news
listen oh no no no no no they did they
do not Michelle Obama do you I'm sorry
we all like Dr Biden eight years of
Obama where conservative media said the
most awful racist sexist things about
Michelle Obama I don't think any of this
should be said I think absolutely oh
again there's there's a there's a first
lady now her name is Dr Jill Biden and
they [__] hate that doctor is in
front of her name give me she's like a
real doctor well neither are you you
[__] armchair doctors like the people
on Twitter who are like you're not a
real doctor it's like yeah you're also
not [__] smart enough to get your PhD
numbnuts
this is all true I got one uh I've got a
couple more Clips you guys got a few
minutes we might go long yeah you got a
few minutes this first one is um from
Ukraine and I want to point this out
um I found this account
um this morning and um this this is uh
and I know I don't point out Ukraine
enough because we focus a lot on
um are our domestic narrative here but
um this is part of the domestic
narrative and the reason why is because
when you see this just think of all the
[__] U.S congressmen all the [__]
senators all the governors and Trump who
are [__] Putin sympathizers here and
and just watch this video and it it'll
[__] gross you out of why it's
[__] despicable and borderlining on
treason to [__] support Putin in this
war against Ukraine
you know in the United States of America
we don't really know what bombed out
buildings are you know that uh the only
two reference points that we have are uh
Oklahoma City and the World Trade Center
and imagine if all over our country
we saw sites like this this is a school
this is a gymnasium where children play
and so this is happening uh all over
Ukraine certainly all over the dunbas
where we stand right now and
um I just think it's important for
Americans to see this imagine if this
was happening
thousands of times in the United States
of America the response that we would
Mount
um so we're just doing our best to
communicate that back to Americans so
that we take action for people who just
want to live free and want to educate
their children in places like this and
uh provide a better brighter and better
future for them now I have to tell you
uh before you guys come in I I have to
say that
when these people who who absolutely
[__] support the gun lobby who
support
um anyone getting a weapon and carrying
into school and murdering [__] uh
elementary students it's not surprising
that they look at this go and I still
support Putin it's really not surprising
it's the same [__] it's the same
goddamn [__] it really is they don't
care about children they don't care
about saving the children they don't
care about Freedom They Don't Care About
Liberty they only care about their
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people at all costs at all costs they
don't give a [__] that's why they love
Putin and that's why they want to be on
his side is because he he is the image
of their ideology he truly is because he
doesn't give a [__] about Freedom he
doesn't give a [__] about children he
doesn't really truly give a [__] about
about Liberty that's all [__] and
that's why they support Putin and that's
why they support this that's why they
support the gun lobby and they support
our children being [__] murdered all
over this country so I just want to
throw that out there I thought it was a
um well you know there's such a
difference between us and them it's and
I say it all the time we are better than
they are we spend a fortune Tony on our
military to generate smart weapons we
can hit a building across the street
from a school and not destroy the school
we spend our Fortune to be humanitarian
about the way we wage war and I mean so
much so that Hamas was moving actually
moved their headquarters inside
hospitals
so that we couldn't hit them anymore
because we were hitting them all around
these civilian targets
you know and and just decimating they
actually moved into freaking hospitals
to hide and look at the way the Russians
act and and how the right Wingers
support them they'd level
schools you know they they had buildings
marked with crosses you know look this
is a hospital the Russians targeted that
that building you know they did it in
cave when they were first trying to take
Keith people went to uh uh an auditorium
there and they marked it they said
children they hit that building on
purpose
and these right-wing [__] sit there
and support Putin they they lick his
ball sack today to this day
you know I'm no I'm no magic Library
these people in Congress have these
briefings they know that these Russian
[__] are doing this and they support
him
anyways
yeah we're [__] better than you we
are better than you
and I don't apologize for saying it well
I don't think you should I don't think
you should um here's another example
what is it called of um why why we in
the in the world of Common Sense and
Liberty are better this is in the
Missouri legislator
um at my home state and um this is a
Democrat questioning simply questioning
the bill that they passed the anti-trans
children bill that they passed in
Missouri it's a bigoted bill it's
designed to ostracize and to marginalize
and already marginalized group in
Missouri but to demonize them and to
cast them out of society but watch watch
as this Democrat questions a Republican
and folks I want you to remember this
line of questioning and really you
should you should listen to this um
several times and just use it when
you're talking to people out there that
are saying this type of hate that they
don't know a [__] thing about they
don't know anything about it they just
know that it makes them feel
uncomfortable because it makes them feel
uncomfortable they don't want it to
exist but it's a them problem problem
not not a not a trans people problem
it's the people who are uncomfortable
with it that it's your problem that
doesn't not mean we need to legislate
this [__] but watch this exchange this
is incredible what is a girl you're a
doctor I think a girl is a is a is a
human that's born with you know
chromosomes do you think it's important
for kids to play sports I do I think
Athletics should be a part of every
kid's life no bill is a perfect bill
and so we're passing laws now gentlemen
and we're not talking about a large
group of people right no we're not how
many people are intersex uh I I can't
tell you that I can't statistics 1.7
exhibit uh intersex traits that's
actually about the same as having red
hair are you familiar with when the
first gender affirming Clinic that did
transition surgeries existed I am not
aware of when that existed okay I'll
tell you have you ever heard of Magnus
hirschfeld I have not Magnus hirschfeld
the hirschfeld clinic in 1930 was the
first trans Clinic they performed
surgeries it was a safe place for Trans
and lgbtq folks to to come and be there
do you know what happened after they
built a medical library of information
researching the complexities of
sexuality and human uh gender I don't
know what happened it was the first Nazi
book burning when they burned the entire
Library saying that it was sexually
explicit material and then executed half
the people involved
because first they came for the trans
kids
do you want this to be your legacy as
the floor leader of the house I I'm not
aware of of that I'll take your words
gentlemen you're out of time
a gorsey's out of time of course he's
out of time he's had a time and he's out
of [__] to give to be quite honest and
and folks I'm telling you I've been
saying it for [__] two years now two
years now that this is the case and
these [__] out there
legislating P trying to legislate people
out of existence whether it's in the
state of Missouri the state of Tennessee
the state of Texas the State of Florida
they're [__] Nazis they may not know
their Nazis but the real Nazis out there
that are self-proclaimed Nazis think
they're [__] Nazis they think they're
[__] Nazis and they think they have
Nazi allies in these legislators
and if you don't understand what the
[__] going on then you better wake the
[__] up and Puck your head out of your
goddamn ass because this trans people
[__] in New
it ain't new it wasn't new it hasn't
been new it's only new because they want
to use it as a wedge to [__] to flood
fascism into our [__] democracy well
[__] that [__] stand against it engage
in your democracy question these
[__] I don't care if they're an
elected official or they're standing in
front of you at the grocery store you
[__] question them you question them
because they don't know what the [__]
they're talking about if they're against
trans people and they're against the
liberty of trans people they don't know
a goddamn thing about it I can guaran
damn T it just like this four leader
who's trying to pass laws to make sure
that trans people don't exist didn't
even know the history of when the first
trans Clinic was opened
didn't know the history of why it was
closed and who [__] closed it and
when he was told that he didn't give a
[__] he didn't care if he's a Nazi he
doesn't care if he's associated with
Nazis he doesn't give a [__] if Nazis
think he's a [__] Nazi and that makes
him a God damn Nazi bet
sorry I didn't mean to get no it's fine
I'll do you one better yeah so when uh
and and new uh and
uh
uh there's a trans bill that was
introduced uh it was anti-abortion so
there's a a Nebraska state senator voted
on an anti-trans and anti-abortion bill
passed by one vote and when questioned
she admitted that she didn't pay
attention to the issue her quote and I'm
quoting what she said here
I don't watch the news or get the
newspaper is there anything going on I
should be aware of
and it's not just the the fact that
people uh you know when questioned in
this debate he's like well I actually
didn't know the history
it's also
current events in in in willingly sane I
didn't stay up to date I don't know
what's going on like you have one job
okay your job is to be a representative
you're supposed to represent your
constituents you're supposed to be well
educated well informed and when it comes
down to actually passing or voting on a
bill that could affect a a population of
people that has already been beaten
physically and verbally
the fact that you're a sitting state
senator
and you didn't do your job you didn't do
the basic research to understand what
they were voting on what they were even
talking about you decide oh you know
what
uh and is anyone can anyone give me the
cliff notes on what's going on like do
you have AIDS did no one inform you like
there's no [__] excuse
for not being aware
of what you're voting on especially when
you might be the one vote that passed
the bill that attacks a trans and it was
a it was an anti-trans and anti-abortion
Bill so if you're the one vote that's
going to be the determining Factor on
whether this passes or doesn't pass and
then when asked about it you're like
well I don't know what's going on anyone
got any info on current events for me so
then what are you doing what have you
been doing well Texas Paul that's the
point is that they don't as long as it
has to do with hate they don't give a
[__] they don't care what the truth is
as long as it is designed to hate
because that's their that's their
[__] personality
yeah and and I've tried to point this
out multiple times that these people
didn't the the one the oligarchs that
are behind it that use the institutions
that used that that use folks like Chris
Ruffo I talk about him all the damn time
he was out of the Manhattan Institute
he's with the Danube Institute in
Hungary this guy didn't invent this [__]
he is following a Playbook that worked
before
and it's exactly what you're talking
about Tony they're freaking Nazis and
they're following for the exact same
Playbook
you know the the and they've got
billions of dollars behind them
you know it's just us sitting here a
couple swinging dicks in front of a
microphone
fighting this [__] they have billions of
dollars funding them
and they're literally following the Nazi
Playbook
I mean the the whole gerbils thing about
tell the LIE repeatedly keep it a simple
lie as short as possible but make it a
big lie
you know I mean it's they're following
his the Nazi Playbook
100 percent
to the they've literally broken the
history books out now and they're saying
okay at this point the Nazis did this
they attacked the trans people and it
worked it worked we use the churches
say you're protecting the kids and
attack the trans people and you will
have these people already you'll have
the momentum they're already doing what
you say
so the next thing will be much easier
and that's when they get that's when
they get to the next thing will be it'll
move from trans trans people to
homosexuals then from homosexuals it
will move to non-Christian religions it
will be the Jews it will be the Muslims
it'll be the atheists it'll be all of
them to protect the children for God's
sakes we have to separate these people
and it won't start with we're going to
kill these people
it'll be that we're going to help them
we're going to educate them we're going
to give them the mental health help they
need and we're going to just do it over
here in this camp with razor wire on it
and that's how we get there wait that's
how we get there we got breaking news
and Gage just put a link in
um uh Rhonda Santos will launch his
presidential bid with Elon Musk what the
[__] does that mean so basically what's
going to happen is he's going to make an
announcement he's going to have a
conversation with him on I'm assuming on
Twitter on Wednesday tomorrow Ron
DeSantis is going to announce he's
running for president during a
conversation with Twitter CEO Elon Musk
and guess what he's gonna do it guess
where he's gonna do it Tony
a [__] Twitter space
[Music]
Rhonda santis is going to promote and
announce
his bid to run for the president of the
United States on a Twitter space Oh my
god listen
at 6 PM Eastern okay and everyone's
gonna be moderated by the [__] other
fascists David sacks okay so listen and
the reason why I'm laughing is because
there is no better [__] failed launch
to do this from an E with Elon Musk in a
Twitter space do you guys remember the
[__] rocket that spontaneously
combusted a couple weeks ago
all right I can't I can't are you
serious he's actually going to start off
this campaign spontaneously combusting
on Twitter is that what he's gonna do
that's hilarious he decided that his
best effort instead of you know what
people normally do which is I'm gonna
have a video announcement I'm gonna go
somewhere I'm gonna stand on the steps
of the Capitol whatever might be and
announce my my my run or my campaign he
goes you know what actually uh people
catch me in weird moments on on video I
laugh weird I interact with people weird
I I I speak weird audio only right
I'm a robot like I'm an Android
glitching out so he thinks that the best
way is he's like look if I don't have to
confront people
I can just talk on here and I can I can
prepare and if there's any sort of lag
on the Audio I can always or like in lag
and delay in my speaking I can always
say oh there's an audio issue or there's
a lag in my connection or whatever
the I have you ever seen have you ever
seen I want to ask you you've watched a
lot of video of Elon Musk have you ever
seen him have any charisma at all ever
you know the most Charisma I've seen is
uh if you watch the interview with him
where he was interviewed by uh by uh
Tucker Carlson before he got fired he
was like
that's the modest about so so not only
does he end no Charisma he has less than
Ron DeSantis which Rhonda Santos has
zero right it's pretty hey what's the
cat's name what's the cat's name by the
way Texas Dolly Parton ah Dolly Parton
oh Jesus Christ
you're so full of [__] okay so so here's
the thing here's the thing that I love
about this most and then we gotta go
because we're way over time
is that Rhonda said Ron dude I've been
telling you to get him for weeks this is
not what I meant ma'am this is not what
I meant at all like I love this I love
that you're gonna do it this way because
this is certainly just losing from the
get-go like this is great man you know I
have any idea how much I'm going to mock
you uh next week and for the for the
months to come as you [__] Propel
downward uh in the polls As Trump says
but propelled downward into unpopularity
when you have Elon Musk help you
announce your presidential bid this is
the guy you picked the person who has
less Charisma than you who has zero this
is [__] fantastic I can't tell you I
mean I'm excited to watch two Androids
trying to have a conversation with each
other that'd be fantastic this is
this is great for our democracy folks
that Rhonda santis thinks Elon Musk is
the way to do it Texas Paul it's Tuesday
I'm glad you're here every Tuesday
everyone go see the link down below
realtexaspaul.com it's
realtexaspaul.com follow him everywhere
go watch his show on Sunday text Paul
the hammer anything else you want to
shamelessly plug
yeah I'm gonna I'm picking up another
show I'm gonna start doing in one uh
Sunday and then one on Wednesday so
we're gonna catch me same time I'm
moving it just a little bit later a lot
of folks on the west coast were
complaining oops we're complaining that
they didn't want to get up at seven
o'clock in the morning to catch the show
so I think we're gonna bump it back to
the 10 o'clock hour and do two shows one
on Sunday one on Wednesday gotcha so go
to realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexasball.com you can go to his
YouTube channel from there and you can
subscribe and you can watch his show on
Sundays and now on Wednesdays Gabe you
got anything you want to shamelessly
blood before we leave I know you
probably got a what was that coming yeah
I gotta what was that coming on uh on
Ted Cruz wanting to attack Bud Light uh
because he doesn't have anything else to
do
um I'm sure I'm gonna have to do what
was that on this Rhonda Santos Elon Musk
absolutely [__] announcement but hell
yeah so go to what was thatshow.com or
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez uh go
check out what he's doing with what was
that why you're on patreon make sure to
visit mine page two patreon.com the Tony
Michaels don't forget to sub subscribe
right here on the Tony Michaels YouTube
channel also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google and if
you want to watch on on Facebook if you
still are over there on Facebook follow
us at the Tony Michaels you can watch it
live every single day live live live
also I want to thank everyone for
following us on Twitch today and getting
us to the subscriber number to 205. we
busted through the 200 goal of
subscribers listen it's free to follow
us on Twitch it is free as [__] free 99
but if you've got a Prime account you
can link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account and you can give us
a subscription one free that you get
with your Amazon Prime account and it
gives us a couple bucks each month you
have to renew it each month so if you
haven't renewed it go ahead and renew it
we're at 205. I'll keep you up to date
let's move the goal number to 300 folks
let's get it to 300 I appreciate all the
support you guys are the greatest in the
world
you know we're going to be back tomorrow
and the day after that the day after
that every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch same time
same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon